experts from the international atomic
energy agency are on their way to
ukraine's occupied zaparisia nuclear
power plant iaea head rafael grossi says
the team will visit the plant later this
week russia and ukraine accuse each
other of artillery strikes near the site
the attacks are fueling fears of a
catastrophic radiation leak officials
say radiation levels are still normal
but people living in the area are
preparing for the worst
people are queuing up in towns near the
zaporizia power plant for this green
tablet
it's iodine and could help protect them
against a radioactive leak
[Music]
we were told that an adult should take
one tablet i have a child they should
take half a tablet
they've been worried about a nuclear
disaster since earlier this year
soon after russia invaded ukraine
we bought it the first time in winter
when the plant was shelled the first
time
emergency workers are training for the
worst
moving victims who have been exposed to
a radioactive cloud
cleaning them
and testing levels of radiation on each
other
the zapo regia power plant is europe's
largest nuclear facility ukrainian
workers have continued to run it
throughout the war but it's occupied by
russian forces which ukraine says
compromises safety
there's lots of heavy equipment at the
plant
infantry combat vehicles trucks and even
tanks
and worst of all is that in the last
three weeks they put this equipment near
the power units number one and number
two
it means there are now like mines
russia and ukraine blame each other for
shelling around the facility as the
power plant stands exposed
well for more we're joined by our
correspondent diane philip schultz who's
in the ukrainian capital kiev good to
see you jan phillip so the un's nuclear
watchdog is on route to zapposia what
more can you tell us
yes exactly we are also hearing reports
that the international
inspectors are on their way right now
and they will probably arrive at the
plant in the second half of the week
this is also consistent with
announcement
announcements that the agency made
some days ago a lot of observers
expected the trip to be imminent
especially after putin gave up his
opposition to the idea of the
inspectors traveling through
non-occupied territory in ukraine
here in ukraine the observers the
inspectors the team of experts they are
definitely very welcome
and people here are seriously concerned
about a possible disaster
there have been reports
regarding
power outages over the weekend new power
outages and also renew renewed fighting
directly around the plant in the past 24
hours
jan phillip there have been
contradictory accounts from ukraine and
russia about what's going on at the
zaparia plant is there any way to verify
what's actually happening
international reporters can't travel to
the site at the moment so there is no
possibility to verify the information
firsthand however we have talked to many
employees that are still working at the
plant and we've also talked to the
town's mayor where the plant is located
at the same time we have russia's
history of
systematic disinformation
disinformation that can easily be
falsified so we can almost say for
certain that russia is using the plant
as a military basis and that there have
been false flag attacks by russia on the
planet but having said this uh there are
also strong indications that uh
ukrainian troops have attacked the plant
several times in the past
weeks and also the town's mayor didn't
deny that there have been ukrainian
attacks around the plant
jan philip we've seen in the report and
you've mentioned as well there's
obviously concerns about radiation what
do we know though about the radiation
levels at the plant
the good news is that the recent
measurements
at the plant and
very close to the plant have all been
within the normal range and the
emergency systems seem to be in place as
we heard in the report authority in the
report authorities are continuing to
distribute iodine iodine tablets so
there is no
way to say everything is okay but the
radiation levels are in normal range at
the moment and everybody is looking
forward for the team of international
experts to arrive
thank you jan phillip jan philipp
schultz in kiev
despite its major military efforts
russia's territorial gains in eastern
ukraine have been limited uw
correspondent young philip schultz
traveled to a frontline region where he
met ukrainians trying to get on with
their lives despite the dangers they
regularly face
we're on the road in eastern ukraine 20
kilometers from the front line in the
last small town before the combat zone
signs of war are all around
at the local supermarket soldiers do
their weekly grocery shopping before
heading back to the trenches
the situation is tense in recent days
the russians have stepped up their
attacks
in this semi-abandoned front-line town
diana and alina want to serve the best
cappuccino east of kiev
we hear the missiles flying over us and
we hear them exploding it's scary
it sounds always so terrifying but we
try to get on with our work
at first their small conflict zone cafe
was an insider tip now soldiers often
queue up outside for half an hour of
peace and a slice of homemade cake
when we get a break from the fighting we
come straight here for coffee
diana is proud that they haven't closed
their cafe for a single day since the
war started only once have they been
forced to take evasive action when
russian strikes came really close and
people ran for shelter
when we heard the shelling we went to
hide in a safe space after a few minutes
we went back to work
the women have set up their own small
emergency aid center directly above the
cafe
here they collect food medicine and
hygiene products for families fleeing
the surrounding villages some of it is
donated some they buy with their own
money
we especially try to help the smaller
children who arrive here from the
occupied territories we have everything
diapers clothes toys all the things they
need to feel better
diana and alina have got used to working
in a cafe on the front line still they
hope one day to use the emergency room
again for its original purpose having a
good time